hey I was going bros my name is fanny
pack welcome back to some more Walking
Dead into the deep episode one last
episode we started off on a boat and
we're shipwrecked and we're going to
another boat and to find parts to save
our boat there's also a mysterious lady
out there who's crying for help
sure it's quiet out here huh but it sure
is quiet out here and stop talking over
peacefully probably a good sign
trouble usually isn't quiet I suppose
that makes you the exception Oh that
dead bodies I didn't know they floated
someone know something's really been
bothering me
I have to ask why does your butthole
decline do you think this looks dumb Oh
what I don't know it's been giving me
[ __ ] about it says I look like a pirate
how do you think be honest a [ __ ] oak
what does he know I knew you alright I
think your ties they look to you how do
you get pierced an email of a popular
loosen up sooner or later you're always
so serious it's kind of exhausting
not much to laugh about these days okay
not that it ever stopped you being grim
about it does that make it all okay you
know we first brought you on board never
thought oh my god that's embarrassing
he's rowing the wrong way around
take off the minute you got your
strength back I keep expecting to wake
up and find this dinghy gone and you
with it if he's supposed to be a sailor
cuz he's rowing the wrong way having got
sick is this your way of telling me to
get out Oh Elmo
I'm just glad as all right now it's
Misha sighs someone out here didn't
imagine going it alone like you why do I
care not for that long anyway oh wait
it's not I mean I saw what you were
about to do you haven't had it easy I
know you mostly keep it to yourself I
don't want to make you talk about it I
didn't I just stopped me
you pull the gun out around hand if you
hadn't shown up to my contact lense
figured I owed you it's morning now you
know for this I was just on my own like
you were convinced myself I liked it
that way well after a while I just oh my
god oh my [ __ ] Lord [ __ ] swimming
zambese go back to sleep mermaids how
can there be so many Sun doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense oh my god they're
swimming they walk on water that's
awesome well they can't want that face
freakin waters in oh this can't be good
water zombies we're in their natural
habitat right now I got a press cute
really really fast here there we go
thank you hey I know you got air but
that can't be good
why how many stabs in the brain do they
need I would swim like the wind man this
is giving me oh he's fine
oh they just wanted to vote they just
wanted to but we're lucky stuff in the
water that might grab you gives me major
anxiety a dit 10 times worse is almost
us I can't in line guess I should have
kept my mouth shut up here believe it
something funny pee huh
what the hell are you laughs I am I
guess I just left that phone I'm scared
shitless
nice face
I don't like this might be someone who
can tell us where everyone went
there's no sign of anyone
just those [ __ ] crows they're
probably all dead meat we don't know
that well unless we can find another
boat looks like we're stuck here looks
abandoned see if we can find your
friends doesn't look like anyone's here
anymore
oh no Shane find something inside looks
like there's two ways in the ladder or
the window do I get a pink ladder seem
oh look at this a grab hey crab how you
doing I think I think a ladder is
probably the better choice all right
let's hope this thing holds you can hold
it steady for you don't fall Thanks
oh okay well that's cool we're in the
boat now in the boat I'm sailing oh
we're not in the boat yet
are you serious
they're like party crashers oh no
they're like the no one wants them there
but they always show up hey hurry
why'd you help him how is that possible
hey you're in quite a pickle Pete
there you go Pete we did it yeah good
job Pete I almost got you Pete oh
they're safe now cuz zombies can't climb
ladders all this time we we thought they
didn't know how to do it
oh she mentioned mob jack this place was
someone's home this is the boat is
called mob Jack do you think your
friends came through here it's hard to
be sure we should look around how can
she not have drawn that conclusion yet
let's look at the map maybe then she'll
discover it baby we'll find something
down there we'll have to go through the
cafe to get to the stairs you're just
looking for mr. honey bars always always
always looking from this dad locked the
emit if one of us can get our hand
through here
maybe we can unlock it
blades too thin I'm just breaking well
then I don't know what if we examine
over here at this bench that is the
place isn't in great shape thank you for
that
Michonne thank you very much what is
inside this perhaps again that's a
little hunk of old metal whoo just like
we needed how convenient
let's grab this hunk of metal and hunk
up some hunk am i right ladies
up top thank you very much well that was
fun
nice I think the pauses are a little too
difficult in this game I don't know what
I feel about it
okay looks safe right click tip I don't
see anything
doesn't mean they're something new
though the question is which one of us
wants to reach in there to open it I'll
do it one of us has to do it I'll do it
one of us have to I'll do it here does
nothing
be careful I'm always careful
Oh
what the [ __ ]
yeah need some help be ready when you
are
3c oh okay don't worry I'll never do
ready ha ha sounds like we're mushing
something like a cake perhaps it's a
cake most likely a cake come on
I was Sam baked you're welcome a lot of
learning screens all the sudden what
happened here no one knows what we could
have just climbed in come on I guess the
window was the better option Oh God
they're fine these aren't your friends
no no
well that's a good thing right they
don't look like walkers wonder what
happened to them they shot himself we
got zip ties the wrists are zip tied he
couldn't fight back
whoever did this made sure they wouldn't
come back these people hadn't turned
they were executed Jesus yes
holy [ __ ] it's our note what this one
these are their kids Vanessa said what
she were here if they left this behind
it
Michonne you okay
you've got that look same look you had
winner I can't deal with this not right
now
yeah I understand
I don't who are the kids am i that's
stupid
is it obvious they wouldn't have left
this on purpose
I gotta hope they're still alive
they made it off this thing yeah cuz the
ladder
remember no nevermind learn the cafe
sorry I just had to ooh sexy sexy sexy
oh my god that is the hardest thing I
ever seen if we're gonna find anything
in this boat it'll be in jail we gotta
go pass in that's awesome
all right I ride I ride I ride a man I'm
Michelle I'm Michelle hey how you doing
boy
today I'm gonna look at you yeah you do
jeez so good stir them up and left him
to be oh they hate his dick that's
disgusting that's my nightmare right sir
good night
you really cut a machete that hard I'm
just curious
poor bastard poor bastard rock out you
go
got a cold bandana I would have taken
the banana but we solve their execution
of those people will turn to that poor
man yeah why what could have done that
why are we going in here
it wasn't war wasn't even self-defense
she no one else did this to them they
did it to each other I've seen it before
this world changes the best of us
sometimes for the worst sometimes not
like this
hold up we don't know what's in there
hello who's in there
Yello what do you see I see a duffel bag
is it duffle bag looks like it's in good
shape
any sign of people I don't see anyone
Oh potato chips can everything else but
love this Josh makes no sense
I know but damn we could really use this
stuff let's cigarettes and potato chips
oh my god
marry lilies peaches and beans guy I
used to have these three times a day
breakfast lunch and dinner drove my mom
crazy cigarettes don't show those to
Burt oh we finally just got him to quit
plenty of ammunition
bunch of Medicine do I really have to go
through all of it come from we should
see what else we can find more the girl
maybe should we not get it
babbit a bat bat bat bat bat oh look at
this a fruit beverage know when you're
gonna find another one of these never
know when you're gonna find another one
of these never know when you're gonna
find another one I'm over that he really
would you believe anybody would larged
thanks for pointing that out I would not
have understand that if she didn't say
it ooh a vending machine kick it
you think candy bars are just gonna
magically pour out of it yes hey never
is too dry maybe I'll try and kick you
next I'm a [ __ ]
or that oak will love these what was
that looked foreign
Logan anything empty
Oh
it's probably just a rat jump-scare in
five four three two one
[ __ ]
back up I could I could totally still
stab him
I'm machete at that range he's way more
effective get out of here
Greg what's going on easy
who the hell are you people who are you
look it just i'm Michonne that's Pete
we're just passing through yeah sure you
are
that bag belongs to us just step aside
all right
don't be stupid
I don't want to do this but we need that
stuff so just back up take it it's yours
it's not worth oh yeah shoot him in the
shoulder you dumb [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
Oh
what was he a vampire what happened I
thought I could pick which order I
wanted I didn't know it was like a
QuickTime sequence
sorry my bad oopsie okay what was it
EQE let's see if I can do this very
intricate QuickTime event okay wipe
there and then there she's pretty [ __ ]
badass I gotta give that to it is the
flesh is a badass [ __ ]
Oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
punch him in the deck
oh my god me Sean Sean please Sean
please oh my god me Sean me my Sean did
you know ya [ __ ] shank like I like
prison
awkward why not well you're late to the
party hey stay put
Randall [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is Randall
what the [ __ ] is going on on this boat
looks like you caught our thieves nice
job
you man you gotta be kidding me
what is what and you've got help this
time
interesting we're not looking for
trouble okay just let us go we could sit
down and talk it out
we'll talk alright but not here
Oh
I know Sam here didn't do all this get
them all onto the boat and be careful
these new ones aren't [ __ ] around
we'll take him to normal
who's normal
I don't know try anything shoot him
well I hope they don't shoot us I'd be
bad that'd be bad for everyone all right
I will end part two here thank you very
much for watching really look forward to
do another one and I will see breasts in
part 3 if you like if you enjoy watching
and as always stay handsome rest